[Música]
en los caminos polvorientos de una
pequeña aldea un vendedor ambulante
estaba teniendo problemas para vender
sus mercancías había recorrido la zona
hacía solo unas pocas semanas y la
mayoría de los aldeanos ya habían visto
sus productos así que deambulo por las
afueras del pueblo con la esperanza de
encontrar algunos clientes nuevos por
desgracia el camino estaba en gran parte
vacío y El vendedor estaba a punto de
dar media vuelta cuando escuchó un
aullido agudo que venía de la periferia
del Bosque siguiendo los gritos hasta su
fuente descubrió a un tanuki Atrapado
Aunque estas criaturas parecidas a los
mapaches eran conocidas por su astucia
este parecía aterrorizado e indefenso El
vendedor liberó a la criatura en apuros
pero antes de que pudiese ocuparse de
sus heridas escapó hacia la
maleza al día siguiente emprendió su
ruta habitual mientras caminaba
fatigosamente vio una tetera tirada
estaba oxidada y vieja Pero quizás
podría vendérsela a los monjes del lugar
El vendedor la pulió hasta que
brilló llevó la tetera hasta el templo
Mountain y se la ofreció a los solemnes
monjes fue el momento oportuno
necesitaban una tetera grande para un
oficio importante y compraron su tetera
por un generoso precio para abrir la
ceremonia empezaron a servir tazas de té
a cada monje pero la tetera se enfrió
demasiado rápido tuvo que ser
recalentada muchas veces durante el
largo oficio y cuando estaba caliente
parecía que se retorcía en la mano del
vertedor al final de la ceremonia los
monjes se sintieron engañados por su
compra y llamaron al vendedor para que
volviera y diera explicaciones a la
mañana siguiente El vendedor revisó el
recipiente pero no pudo encontrar nada
inusual en él esperando que una taza de
té los ayudara a pensar pusieron la
tetera en el fuego en pocos instantes
antes el Metal empezó a sudar de repente
brotó una cola cubierta de maleza patas
peludas y nariz puntiaguda con un
aullido El vendedor reconoció al tanuki
que había liberado El vendedor se
sorprendió había oído historias del
tanuki que cambiaba de forma que se
transformaba al tirar de sus testículos
pero eran Generalmente bromistas
problemáticos que gastaban bromas
vergonzosas a viajeros o hacían llover
dinero que después se convertía en hojas
algunas personas incluso ponían estatuas
de tanukis fuera de sus casas y
comercios para engañar a posibles
bromistas para que se llevaran sus
travesuras a otra parte sin embargo este
tanuki solo sonrió dulcemente por qué
había elegido esta forma insospechada el
tanuki explicó que quería recompensar la
amabilidad del vendedor sin embargo se
había calentado demasiado Como tetera y
no le gustaba ser quemado restregado o
Pulido el monje y El vendedor rieron
ambos impresionados por este honorable
bromista a partir de ese día el tanuki
se volvió un invitado apreciado del
templo podía ser encontrado a menudo
contando historias y realizando trucos
que divertían incluso a los monjes más
serios Los Aldeanos venían desde muy
lejos para ver al tanuki del templo y El
vendedor iba a menudo de visita para
compartir té hecho con una tetera
normal Gracias por vernos si te gustó
este video Haz click en suscribirse y no
pierdas nunca la oportunidad de aprender
algo
nuevo
Oh